DNA cloning refers to how we build
customized DNAs for various experiments
in cellular and molecular biology, not
to be confused with the cloning of
whole animals, like Dolly the sheep. We
often need to study a specific DNA,
RNA, or protein, but the natural
version of it expressed in the cell
needs to be tweaked a little bit so we
can study it efficiently. For example,
we might want to add a florescent tag
to see a specific protein under the
microscope. Remember the central dogma
in biology: DNA encodes RNA encodes
protein. So whichever type of
macromolecule needs to be studied, it
is originally expressed from DNA. That
is why we clone at the DNA level. For
ease, we often work with small,
functional circular DNAs on the order
of 10,000 base pairs, called plasmids,
that express the DNA of interest.
Plasmids can replicate and be
maintained in a cell and remain
independent of the genome, and they
will continually express this protein
of interest. Here's an example of a
classic cloning experiment. Remember
what we want-- to overexpress a tagged
protein in the cell. We have a plasmid
expressing the DNA for a protein, in
this example, the human histone. We
want the histone to fluoresce for our
experiments. They usually don't, so we
will add the DNA encoding GFP, which
stands for green fluorescent protein.
We borrowed this DNA sequence from the
jellyfish.
The original method to clone DNA used a
series of purified enzymes. First,
molecular scissors, called restriction
enzymes, cut the plasmid. These enzymes
recognize a very specific sequence of
DNA. Second, the GFP DNA is also cut
with the same restriction enzyme.
Third, we mix the two cut DNAs together.
Their ends have a special affinity for
one another left behind by the
restriction enzymes. Fourth, an enzyme
called ligase bonds the remaining gaps
in the DNAs to make a new plasmid with
GFP fused to a histone. This plasmid
can then be introduced to human cells,
allowing us to study a bright green
tagged human histone by fluorescence
microscopy.